And the answer is, the probability of every sequence becomes small.
This is true because there become more and more sequences.
Every time you flip a coin, you double the number of sequences.
And they have varying probabilities but they are always more against the probability,
always goes down and always multiplying in a number less than 1.
That's why this assumption is important.
The probability of every number of heads become small.
This is a little trickier that this is also true because as the number of flips increases,
the number of heads must increase even if we're assuming some low probability for it.
So, it becomes farther and farther away from what we expect.
The probability of every proportion of heads also becomes small.
This is a little trickier but the thing to remember is--
every proportion of heads, corresponds to a given exact number of heads.
Now that exact number of heads changes as, let's say,
I double the number of flips, I also double the number of heads I need.
But, that's going to always be a smaller number, since again that probability has to be divided
into the chance that I could just have one more head or one less head
which is going to be an ever so slightly different proportion.
Now, this statement is not true.
The probability of every range of proportions can't become small.
The range of all proportions is arranged and we know that has to stay at once,
So, that can't be true and the probability of some ranges of proportions become small.
Well, this will also be true--consider something improbable like
getting the proportion--a proportion below 10% on a fair coin.
That's going to tend to become rare and rare and rare as you flip it more times,
because the same rare or unlikely event has to keep repeating itself.